my work has begun to pursue this even at
the molecular level we were just talking
about bacteria a minute ago but it turns
out that we see the same thing going on
even at the molecular level think about
the simple example of
how DNA produces proteins that have
interesting three-dimensional structures
um DNA has a sequence of nucleotides
every three of them we call a codon it's
interesting we use the the metaphor of a
code here think about Morse code Morse
code is an arbitrary correlation between
dots and dashes and letters
um two conventions
and we've now linked them together with
a conventional Association because dots
and dashes aren't letters
um so we have exactly the kind of thing
that we're struggling with here a
conventional or symbolic form of
communication
um
codon
matches to an anticodon in a messenger
RNA molecule so that in going from DNA
to the messenger RNA it's laid out in
iconic ways
that is the
messenger RNA now is a reflection of an
exact you know reverse isomorphism of
the DNA that took that information from
its nucleotide sequence corresponds
exactly to the one that's produced by
the DNA molecule
um then taken into a ribosome that
structure also made up of DNA I mean of
RNA and protein
um then takes in another kind of RNA
molecule Transfer RNA molecule which has
on one end of it
um three nucleotides which will match
again in anti what we call anticodon
fashion that is the reverse three that
now attaches it iconically to the
messenger RNA molecule
but on the other end of the transfer R
why is it iconically attaches oh because
it's it's a mirror image
so it has all so we might say it
covaries it's a covariance relationship
um and what we mean by if there's a
similarity in this case
um there's an inverse similarity so in
the DNA molecule the A's G C's and T's
um uh match up with
they're opposite so G and C you know
bind together a and t bind together uh
in the messenger RNA
um you replace one of them with another
one called uracil
um which is a slightly slightly related
uh nickel nucleotide and then so now
we've got three things that bind
together I'll say only do it by by
showing so you got RNA molecule binding
of the DNA molecule it's now carries a
mirror image in fact
it's up it's opposite side would be the
DNA molecule but now it then carries
over and binds to here I've got my RNA
molecule coming across here and it binds
to
um another RNA molecule the transfer RNA
molecule
um so that the the three bases in the
DNA molecule mapped to three bases in
the RNA mole in messenger RNA molecule
which may up to three bases in the
transfer RNA molecule which is now since
this is the the reverse the mirror image
now it binds again and you've got the
original image back
so what you have is you've maintained
the form
the form or what I would call the
constraint the sequence constraint has
been maintained so we would say that by
covariance relationship information has
been transferred okay okay so
constraints is the same as information
in this case or no so what I'm going to
show you is is how they're this the same
but it turns out there's a hierarchic
relationship that we have to keep in in
mind in order to show this this was lost
in information Theory originally in the
1940s and 50s and it needs to be brought
back and I'll explain why in a minute
um but the idea is that so now there's a
covariance relationship we've passed
this covariance
from one molecule to another molecule to
a third molecule that transfer RNA
molecule has also got at the other end
of it an amino acid and each three
codons on one end is matched to a
specific amino acid on the other end
that amino acid is now brought together
these three attached to the next three
to the next three different amino acids
correspond to the different codon
and now by bringing together
um different Transfer RNA molecules
you're also bringing together
different
amino acids
so that now what's happening there's a
continuity relationship or a correlation
relationship
that correlation relationship is now
also correlating amino acids which tend
to get stuck together and they produce a
long string of amino acids that is coded
for in the sequence in the DNA molecule
so now we have gone from a DNA molecule
by a covariance relationship and to the
RNA molecule which has a correlational
relationship and neighboring Transfer
RNA molecules now provide amino acids
with a correlational relationship so by
virtue of taking
um similarity relationship covariance
relationship and then a correlation
relationship we've now allowed DNA
molecule which has no relationship to
proteins as as molecules proteins are
made up of totally different molecules
in a string that tend to fold up because
of their electrical and hydrophobic and
hydrophilic potentials into
three-dimensional structures
that a linear structure has passed its
information on through these multiple
steps to a totally different kind of
molecule
which can now interact with other
proteins and other kinds of molecules to
produce most of the work of the cell
what's happened is the reason we call
this a codon relationship is there's a
code-like relationship between them that
is
um what we've done is we figured out in
biology now Evolution has figured this
out so to speak
um how to take
um a linear relationship in one kind of
molecule and create a particular kind of
three-dimensional molecule made up of
totally different kinds of atoms that is
made up of amino acids as opposed to
nuclei nucleotides and
its function is determined by its
three-dimensional structure by how it's
folded
so in effect there's almost no
relationship between them you it's this
is why thinking of it as a code it's not
crazy it's it's arbitrary
and yet the arbitrarity has been
produced by this multi-step process that
links covariance with correlation
in a way that allows this to happen that
I like to call covariance relationships
and correlation relationships grounded
they're grounded because the vehicle
that carries it is carrying some feature
in common with what it represents with
the information that it's carrying so if
it's a like this relation if it's a
covariant covariance relationship it's
carrying some kind of formal feature
forward into another kind of molecule
whereas if it's just physically
correlated struck together
not by virtue of likeness but by simply
by virtue of being next to each other
being correlated being attached
um that also is grounded physically
grounded one is formally grounded and
one is physically grounded okay but by
stacking one on top of the other it now
produces the kind of distance between
where you started and where you end so
that now there's a what I call displaced
reference the information in the DNA
molecule is there in the protein but in
a totally different form there's been a
continuity of information transfer but a
complete loss of roundedness
at the physical level and yet there's an
informational ground in this because
you've transferred
the same correlations
as a result there can be selection that
affects proteins and how they interact
and that'll select for particular
sequences of genes that produce those
useful proteins even though they're
totally separate kinds of molecules
it adds one further feature that I think
is also important to think about it in
terms of the mathematics of all of this
that is the protein now has a
three-dimensional structure but DNA also
has a three-dimensional structure it's
twist and its twist is slightly
different depending on which
nucleotides are in that sequence
now my watch is talking to me just a
minute let me set it down it's all right
we'll repeat that last part the DNA so
the DNA sequence is of nucleotides but
it turns out that we we think about the
DNA molecule as as a Twist as a helix it
turns out that the Helix is slightly
differently Twisted depending on the
sequence
so it's not a uniform twist all the way
up so depending on the actual rung in
the ladder or depending on a sequence of
rungs no depending on the sequence of
Rooks the sequence of rungs make it
tight more tightly twisted or more
Loosely twisted depending on what the
sequence is and that means that there's
a three-dimensional structure to the DNA
molecule so it turns out that there are
some proteins that are produced produced
by virtue of being you know the
information taken off the DNA molecule
that are structured in such a way that
they can bind into the twist so there's
information that's passed from the DNA
to the protein and then there's also
structural information in terms of the
zeros and ones that we ordinarily think
of so those are the rungs and then
there's also structural information in
the sense that certain sequences of
those zeros and ones physically produce
a different structure in the DNA and
right it's not to say necessarily that
the protein then copies that but it
somehow relates no no the proteins don't
copy they want to be clear what what
this says is that because
the protein molecule is a totally
different kind of molecule but it has
three-dimensional shape
what that means is that some proteins we
call them transcription factors
actually bind to DNA by
fitting with a Twist
and since that twist is determined by
the sequence
then what's happened is that the
proteins identify a region of the DNA
molecule
and as a result those proteins can play
a role in up regulating or down
regulating the expression of genes
so now you have recursion possible
so what's happened by virtue of this
displacement from one kind of
information
that is sequence information zero and
one information you might think about it
um two three-dimensional physical
information
because they are both embodied
physically
they're capable of interacting but now
on a totally different basis
now the protein can regulate the DNA
that produces proteins
by virtue of this displacement of
reference
it's possible to now have that displaced
molecule regulate the kind of molecule
that produced it
this is recursion but notice that this
is a kind of interesting recursion it's
very similar to the gridelian recursion
but you need to have even a simple
Paradox like a liar's Paradox is that
you can't stop interpreting because it
refers to itself the Liars Paradox the
simplest one is of course this statement
is a lie or this statement is false
um once you interpret it you have to
reapply it back to the statement
originally you can't stop interpreting
because if it's a lie then it must it
must not be true but if it must not be
true then it's a lie then it's a lie so
it must be true the classic the classic
circularity here this is the basis in a
much more complicated version of
girdle's incompleteness proof for
mathematics
um that is basically you have to have
some way that something can refer to
itself it has to have this kind of
recursion the point here is that that
recursion is possible with DNA and
proteins because of this displacement
DNA and RNA have to be linked to each
other by likeness relationships
um but DNA and proteins have totally
different reasons for having the
physical structures they they have but
as a result now you can have DNA
modified DNA indirectly through proteins
this hierarchy of communication in very
simple genetics is what makes possible
the complexity of bodies and cells
you've got to have this kind of
recursion because now the DNA can play a
role through Communications through
other interactions with the cell because
the proteins are now carrying
information also about their interaction
with other proteins maybe even with the
world that information can now modify
how genes produce and expressed
um so the complexity becomes possible I
people in semiotics have talked about
this as scaffolding that is you're
building up new levels of information
that can now be a basis for building up
yet higher order information
so in fact this relationship I've just
talked about is what makes it possible
to have
um
complicated multi-celled bodies that
have repeated Parts think about the
multiple legs on insects or the multiple
ribs or the multiple vertebrae in our
bodies this is the result of exactly
this kind of transcription Factor effect
that is proteins that produce genes that
modify other genes well it turns out
that that with by a series of other
features
um genes have duplicated and varied and
you're producing this in a sort of theme
and variation fashion once you have
recursion you can do sort of theme
variation effects
um higher order effects and this is what
produces the sort of the what you might
call the theme and variation repeated
bodily parts that makes plants and
animals possible
so in effect what I became very
interested in and this is really uh
by the end of the 1990s
was not only that I'm finding that
there's a lot of
um
indirect causality that makes this
possible in the brain and how it must
have been possible neurologically but it
now tells me that there's a way that
this is relevant to biology and maybe
something as universal as mathematics
itself that this same hierarchical
relationship how you get recursion how
you make recursion possible
um has to do with this what I call I I
describe this sort of characteristically
as one two three repeat
one
the iconicity that is the co-variation
okay two
correlation physical correlation in some
respects and three displacement
once you've displaced you can now go
back and have that displaced reference
modify one
two three repeat
um is giving you this this capacity for
recursion you just watched a clip from
the theories of everything channel for
the full video and all its magnificence
then click here and if you'd like to see
more then subscribe enjoy